it's very cool to have a moment where  it's like this is a thing and people are  into it I was lucky enough to be part of  this this is pretty awesome we want  everyone to see how fun it is to  participate to watch to cheer on your  favorite teams your your country in your  town  overwatch League seems like a fantastic  adventure that's what I was looking for  at that time like an adventure to go on  my mind was blown  I think this is fantastic this is what  we know this is what we do it's a lot of  work but it's the best job in the world  I'll give them one last chance to really  make the most out of my love for gaming  well I never seen something like this  before the fan reaction is borderline  magical I think there's so much to be  excited about in the future  you  [Music]